i'm geeked out about this segment for
game show junkies this is the ultimate
training ground next weekend you can
attend a game show boot camp and even
better it's all for a great cause here
to talk about that is a las vegas legend
set all sorts of records during his
jeopardy run james holsauer and we're
joined by kelly christo the executive
director for project 150 that's the
non-profit that will benefit from the
game show boot camp john kelly thank you
so much for being here today thanks for
having me john
[Laughter]
wait wait see already i got james i got
it right in the intro
but we'll just go with james for now
yeah uh james man it's been how long
since your jeopardy run uh about three
years since the initial run and uh two
and a half since the greatest of all
time tournament it's quite a whirlwind
yeah and did you ever anticipate that
like ever before you went on jeopardy
had it been something you'd always
wanted to do going on the show
definitely something i always wanted to
do and i kind of wanted to do it my own
way i wasn't sure i'd be successful as i
was but i thought hey i have a good
strategy here i'm going to try it out
and see what happens
well obviously it turned out okay i
would say project 150 has been around
for a while you've been with them for
about five years almost almost and tell
us for people who don't know what
project 150 is all about and how you'll
benefit from the game show bootcamp of
course so project 150 helps the homeless
displaced and disadvantaged high school
students here in southern nevada we
provide basic necessities like food
clothing school supplies hygiene
products we even do college scholarships
so basically our mission is to make sure
these kids have all their basic
necessities stay in school and graduate
so yes we are the beneficiary of this
lovely event happening august 20th the
titan throwdown with a bunch of jeopardy
champions i mean these are the heavy
hitters these are all the heavyweights
so never been done before one night only
live i don't think we've ever
had all the titans together like this
this is kind of a first of its kind
event so we have two things we have a
broader weekend called the game show
boot camp which i don't think anyone's
ever tried this before it's like tips
from the actual pros you know people who
have been on the shows we have people
have been on the contestant side we have
me brad rutter amy schneider we also
have maggie speak who was the executive
producer on jeopardy for 30 years she's
given people like direct advice on how
you pass your audition for it's not just
jeopardy any game show out there you
know what the producers are looking for
how you can present your best self and
then on saturday night august 20th we
have our main event the titan throwdown
we have 10 game show legends you know a
lot of people from the chase the queen
victoria gross will be there mark lebet
the beast some great jeopardy champions
uh amazing yeah just all for a good
cause 100 of all proceeds go to charity
you can you can compete against us you
can buy tickets
you can buy a ticket to just watch
listen i called you john so i think i've
already eliminated from the competition
so yeah we have uh options you know if
you just want to come watch this great
event that's great if you want to come
down and take us down that's even better
you know
is this for people who aspire to
jeopardy or any game show any game show
you know we have directives i mean
to some extent they're looking for the
same things on jeopardy you gotta you
know know a little more trivia sure but
you the the same tips go for everyone
you know be your best self present a
calm confident voice while you're up
there yeah all kinds of stuff well
that's a lot of fun now we're going to
do a little jeopardy round between the
three of us you ready kelly oh gosh
i predict kelly wins
so am i reading the questions
i think you're reading it
so i i read the questions all right so
here are the questions i guess you two
will compete maybe i guess oh i can
compete too because i don't know the
answers to these how do we ring in
that's a good question anyway we have
jeopardy using music playing now that
you can't okay so the first question is
this
all right the first answer i should say
the south this southwestern state in the
u.s also has a city named las vegas
[Music]
and what is new mexico new mexico is the
correct answer
kelly takes the early lead
james come on man all right the next one
it's ten fantasy suites feature roman
egyptian or pompeian decors
uh no no
i say what is caesar's palace
all right all right here we go
this is the last one filmed in reno the
movie the misfits was the last picture
for this
gone with the wind star going with the
wild
gone with the wind because i i've never
heard of gone with the wild so that's
what they said in the property all right
so gone with a win star
all right who is clark gable and the
answer is yes who is clark gable also
marilyn monroe's last film
really yeah see now that's that's how
you that's how you know he's a true
jeopardy champion that's fantastic it
was a tie you can you and i can say we
tied him we totally did
he was nothing
all right good luck with the boot camp i
think it's a great idea project 150 is a
great cause james you're always doing
great things in the community so thank
you uh to purchase tickets for the titan
throwdown benefiting project 150 just
visit
thespacelv.com
or scan the qr code that's on your
screen do it quick because it's not
going to be up there much longer we also
have it on our website if you want to
get it there tickets are 100 bucks and
include live viewing of the event
photographs you can get autograph from
james all sorts of fun stuff jillian we
tied james i'm very